[Music]
to say this termite queen keeps busy is
an understatement
in one day the queen can turn out 20 000
eggs along with productivity comes
longevity
queens of the species can live for 20
years
compare that to the workers in the
colony even though they are closely
related
they only survive for a few months
this termite is not the only social
insect that has a vastly different
lifespan depending on its role when
studying lifespan and aging
researchers often focus on model
organisms such as mice
fruit flies or nematodes
far fewer studies look at these
processes in social insects
whose aging takes twists and turns that
rival any sea elegance movements
take the ant species platythyrea
punctada
even though members of this colony have
the exact same dna
the ants that reproduce live for about a
year
regular workers survive to about half
that age
scientists are looking into the
mechanisms behind these aging
differences
in indian jumping ants when a queen dies
workers in the nest duel for the right
to lay eggs
a handful of them will switch from
worker to gamergate
an egg-laying ant in a way they are also
fighting for their lives
these gamergates live about five times
longer than workers
what could be behind this scientists
have found many intriguing differences
between gamergates and other workers
in one example gamergates have 40
percent more
of a certain type of glial cell in the
brain
glia are cells that protect and support
neurons
defects in glia function are connected
with aging in animals
such as fruit flies and mice in a
honeybee colony
even non-breeding members can age
differently depending on their roles
younger workers stay in the hive and act
as nurses
they care for the queen and the brood a
few weeks later
they venture into the world to collect
food for the hive
these foraging bees age and die within
two weeks
damage to a forager's wings can reveal
the telltale signs of aging
perhaps more bizarre a foraging bee
that's called back into the hive to be a
nurse
suddenly reverses aging compared to
foragers
these converted workers have higher
levels of vitilogenin
a multi-purpose protein linked with
longevity
they also learn faster than foragers of
the same age
a dna pathway in the termite queen helps
create its own fountain of youth
researchers have found that they have
relatively low transposon activity
transposons are pieces of dna that hop
around the genome
often they disrupt genes and can cause
mutations
from humans to c elegans older
individuals often have higher levels of
transposon activity
the same thing happens for termite
workers
while promising the field needs some
time to develop
for example there are only a handful of
gene edited ant
and b strains compared to the thousands
of available mice and fruit fly strains
as scientists find better ways to
monitor and tweak genes and social
insects
these colonies of critters may help us
understand aging in ways that other
animals
can't lessons remain from this tale of
button-sized benjamin buttons
[Music]
you